Kingsbury run is the neighborhoods on the Southeast side of Cleveland,
Ohio whose main feature is a natural watershed that drains into the Cuyahoga
river. During the 1930s, ravaged by the great depression,
the area was mainly full of shantytowns that were homes, transience addicts,
and other vulnerable people condemned to reside on the bottom rung of society.
Unfortunately,
these characteristics also make the easy targets for anyone looking for victims
for you. See, Cleveland's also at a monster.
He was real life flesh and blood like you and me and his Savage actions would
make the make-believe monsters of fairytales pale in comparison, who he was,
why he did what he did. We still don't know he was never identified or captured,
but he left behind a dark legacy that forever Tate did the history of
Cleveland's.
And one that we will explore today as we take a look at the mad butcher of
Kingsbury, right
Began on September the 23rd, 1935,
when two boys were spending a nice sunny afternoon climbing and embankments in
Kingsbury run gold Hill,
the site there's a match to them when they reach the top cause to both discrete
and flee and terrorists searching for the nearest adults.
It was the naked body of a man and he didn't have a hat. Detectives,
Ali may and ML missile were the first to arrive on the scene while investigating
the area. They quickly made another grisly discovery.
There was a second victim who liked the first had also been beheaded,
washed and drained of blood.
The official police report described the scene as such the bodies of two white
men, both beheaded buying in the weeds. Both bodies were naked,
except that one of them had socks on after an extensive search.
The heads of both men were found buried in separate places.
One of our it's 20 feet away from one of the bodies and the other head was
buried about 75 feet away from the other body.
Both men's genitals had been severed from their bodies and were found near one
of the heads.
We also found an old blue coat light cap and the bloodstained union suit
nearby was a metal bucket containing a small quantity of oil and torch.
It was apparent that oil acid or some chemical was poured over one of the bodies
as it was burns, to quite an extent,
it was also evidence that both bodies had been there several days as they had
started decompose. The first victim was named Edward and dressy.
He was a 28 year old, former orderly,
who used to work at the psychiatric wards of Cleveland city hospital.
At the time of his murder though, he was unemployed and his wife had left him.
He ended up being one of the few victims of the mad butcher who wherever
identified the police had his fingerprints on file.
As and dressy had had several run-ins with the law as his father put it Edward
associated with people of questionable character.
He had been arrested once when he concealed weapons,
George and had been picked up for intoxication multiple times.
He dealt in pornography,
the got in trouble with gangsters in Detroit and even had an angry husband out
for blood after sleeping with his wife. In other words,
nobody was really shocked at that. And dressy eventually ended up murdered.
Although the were a bit of a surprise.
The second victim remains an unidentified John DOE or victim one,
as he was referred to in the investigation,
he was a middle aged man between 40 and 45 years of age, about five foot,
six tall, 165 pounds with dark Brown hap.
What was established was that he was the mad bushes likely first victim,
while that would interest,
you had been sitting in the grass for two to three days before he was discovered
initial estimates for John DOE said that he had been murdered some seven to 10
days prior. These estimates were later revised,
even further concluding that he had been killed and dumped weeks before and
dressy.
But the chemical agents that his body was treated with that caused it to become
leathery and slowed down decomposition lab analysis also revealed another grease
in detail. Both men were still alive when they'd been decapitated.
[Inaudible].
Since then, dressy was the only one of the two victims who was identified.
Police focus their investigation on his last days,
he left his home on Thursday evening and was murdered the following night with
his Bondi being discovered on Monday afternoon. Unfortunately,
detectives couldn't track down anyone who saw or spoke with Andrew Massey after
he left home,
nor could they find any connections to another missing person who could have
been victim one offer a few weeks of investigations.
The authorities reached some conclusions regarding the case.
Both men were killed by the same person.
This person used a sharp knife for the dismemberment and made clean cuts,
showing knowledge and experience.
These were crimes of passion and one related to any criminal rackets.
They were committed somewhere else.
And the victims were brought to Kingsbury run after the fact with the killer
being strong enough to carry the bodies up the steep embankments of Hill as an
automobile could not claim that way.
While this may have had the makings of a decent start for a criminal profile,
it was nowhere near good enough to identify the murder app with no leads to
follow the police. And only one choice wait for another body. As it turns out,
they may have already had it. Traditionally 12 victims are ascribed to the mat,
but some researchers believe that he may have murdered more.
And the first one actually predated the two bodies found on Hill on September
the fifth, 1934,
the lower half of a woman's torso washed up on the shore near Euclid beach park
at Lake Erie.
It's been in the water for three to four months and had an odd coloration,
which resulted from being treated chemically.
Despite the clear similarities police at the time,
never investigated this as part of the med butcher's murders,
the woman was only retroactively named as possibly being the first victim
becoming known as the lady of the Lake or victim zero.
The next murder came in late January, 1936.
There was another woman showing that the mad butcher had no preference when it
came to gender parts of her body had been raft Kathleen's newspaper and left on
the streets and half bushel baskets.
The other parts were found days later in an empty lot,
callously discarded against a fence I had was never recovered,
but she was identified through fingerprints. She was Florence Flo pillow,
a 42 year old waitress who had been arrested at a few times for prostitution.
And also the only other victim apart from and dressy to be positively
identified. Those who knew Flo Lancto.
She was usually friendly and kind exceptions being when she drank heavily,
which apparently happens quite often because of this,
her marriage fell apart and she had to resort to prostitution to make ends meet
like dressy. She mainly surrounded herself with dubious characters like pimps,
madams, bootleggers, and drug addicts.
And none of them could provide police with clues as to what happened to flow
before her disappearance,
the investigation into a death that soon hit a wall like the other sprints,
because the idea of a serial killer was still relatively new.
The authorities were still not treating these murders is the work of the same
culprits because they lacked a common motive.
The two men found on Jack Hill were killed by the same person,
but as far as they were concerned, Flo polo wins.
The lady of the Lake were unconnected crimes.
[Inaudible].
With no leads.
It was only a matter of time before the killer struck again on the morning of
June, the fifth, 1936,
two boys were passing through Kingsbury run on their way to fishing.
When they saw a pair of pants bunched up and thrown into a Bush,
they prodded it with fishing poles and the head of a man came rolling out the
next day, or authorities found the man's body placed in some bushes,
very close to an office that the railroad police,
whether this was a coincidence or the killer's way of taunting the police.
We don't know the victim was a man in his early to mid twenties,
despite being found near shantytowns. He did not look blank.
He belonged that he was well-groomed clean. Well,
feds had been wearing nice new clothes,
which were dumped in a pile next to his naked body, his underwear,
and had the initials JD on them more distinctly though,
the young man had six tattoos.
Some of them with elements that suggested he might've been a sailor in a very
unusual move.
The police made a death mask of the victim and presented it alongside a chart of
his tattoos and exhibits at the great lakes exposition.
The world's fair that took place in Cleveland,
just a few weeks after the murder,
their thinking was that his face would be seen by hundreds of thousands of
people. And hopefully someone would recognize it.
Unfortunately they had no luck despite the death mask,
despite the tattoos and the initials and the fingerprints,
the victim remained unidentified becoming known as the tattooed man.
Also around this time,
the police were increasingly becoming forced to face an unpleasant reality.
This,
there was a single madman in Cleveland who was killing all of these people by
cutting their heads off.
It was the coroner's office that first took this position,
the decapitations that precision of the cops,
the cleaning and disposing of the bodies. They all suggested one culprits.
However, again,
serial killers were still a novel concept back then one that the investigators
led by Sergeant James Hogan, head of the homicide division,
either didn't consider or more likely preferred to ignore.
They wanted them murders to fall into neat little boxes.
The two men found dead on Jack ourselves. A woman had to be involved.
Somehow the bodies dumped near shantytowns clearly part of some kind of criminal
activity like drugs or prostitution.
It was with extreme reluctance that they finally admitted that the crimes were
all the work of one crazed killer persuaded by a man with an untouchable
character.
Undoubtedly, as if the gruesomeness of the murders wasn't enough.
Another element of fan,
the flames of public interest was the involvement of Elliot ness,
former prohibition agents, and leader of the untouchables. By this point,
he was already famous in the country for his role in taking down Al Capone in
Chicago, even though he was still in his early thirties.
And this was clearly regarded as the new up-and-coming golden bike.
Once prohibition ended Cleveland's mayor Harold Burton,
hardened as the city's safety director,
giving him authority over the police and fire departments.
Burton himself had been elected on a platform of cracking down on crime and
corruption. So obviously nobody fit the role better than Elliot nest.
This happened in December, 1935, by which point,
the mad butcher already claimed several victims that were still being
investigated as separate murders because of alienness as high profile.
His involvement in the torso murders had been exaggerated over the years.
His position was mainly administrative.
He rarely took an active role in the case,
not to mention the fact that his focus was on tackling large scale issues,
such as corruption, drugs, and gambling, not one lunatic with a knife, even.
So he was persuaded by the coroner that the beheadings or the work of just one
man and instructed the homicide division to investigate the crimes as being
committed by a single killer. In the meantime,
the murderer continue to spree unimpeded and other male victim was found just a
month and a half after the tattooed man.
Although he had actually been killed months before he was in an advanced state
of decomposition and remained on identified because there were two unique
elements about this crime. One,
it occurred in the big Creek area in Southwest Cleveland's, far removed trimmed,
Kingsbury run two,
there was a large puddle of dried blood under the corpse that was wet.
He had been murdered as well.
The other victims that all been dumped in different location.
For some reason that we still don't know on this particular occasion,
the killer straight pretty far from his original modus operandi.
Although ultimately it did not yield any useful leads to the authorities.
By this point, the police were looking for one murder,
but the press and the people did not know that. Yes, even those.
Then when you say the headlines,
which speculated that the city had a madman whose strange God is the guillotine
for the moments Elliot ness was providing them with all the headlines and
snapshots they needed by staging raids on gambling dens and taking down corrupt
officials. However,
the next victim alerted the entire nation that Cleveland at a serial killer at
its midst, the body was found on September the 10th, 1936,
when a Vagrant saw two halves of a torso floating in a stagnant pool of water by
the Creek police and rescue unit soon arrived on the scene and use long hooks to
try and recover other parts of the body and items of clothing.
As the hours passed, hundreds of onlookers gathered to see the morbid show,
the media then arrived to ask questions and take pictures.
There was no way it's a hyper story of the torso murders anymore.
Soon enough papers even had a name for the killer.
The man Kingsbury run from this point on Elliot ness,
more involved in the case,
something which she kind of resented since it wasn't what he signed up for him
because it took him away from his other duties where he was markedly more
successful.
Although nowadays he is famous for his work as a prohibition agent against Al
Capone. Thanks to the book,
the TV series and the movie called the untouchables and his own time.
This success faded from public memory and he became chiefly remembered for his
failure to catch the mad bookshop in his position.
There was little that NES could do other than dedicate more resources to the
case.
You assigned a unit of 20 detectives working full time to catch the killer plus
countless patrolman. He told them to investigate every tip,
no matter how trivial or crazy.
And he put out a reward for information leading to the Matt butcher's arrest.
Some of the detectives went undercover as vagrants while others posed as gay men
in bars and steam bars,
hoping that they might lock into the killers hunting grounds of particular note
here was the detective good Peter Marilou. He was considered intelligence,
but eccentric spoke multiple languages and was tenacious in his pursuits
sometimes bordering on obsessive.
He and his partner personally interviewed over 1,500 people for this case,
which included all the stranger suspects whose profiles ended up on that desks
among them was a giant man who walked around Kingsbury run with a kitchen knife.
Another man who claimed he was a voodoo doctor and he possessed a death rate.
And last,
but certainly not least man who liked to hide prostitutes and pleasure himself
while watching them cut heads off chickens.
Despite the risks.
That's, the police made no headway in their case,
in the mad butcher claims and other three victims. The following year,
the first was a woman found in February,
1937 on the shore of Lake Erie in almost the same spot as the lady of the Lake.
Back in 1934,
the second victim was mostly a skeleton because even though she was found in
June, 1937, she had been killed a year prior, despite this,
she had been officially identified as a missing woman named Rose Wallace,
thanks to our dental work. But again, this didn't lead anywhere promising.
The third and final victim of the year was a man whose headless remains were
pulled out of the Cuyahoga river. A month later,
the last three victims were all found in 1938. They were two women and one man,
all remaining unidentified. The last two were discovered on the same day,
very close to each other, although they'd been killed months apart,
those were the final victims, officially ascribed, the mad butcher buts.
There were thoughts that he simply started killing someplace else.
Whenever a killer stopped, suddenly there are three common possibilities.
They died. They were imprisoned on an unrelated charge or they moved away.
Detective Peter,
Marilyn believed that the mad butcher hopped boxcars and started a new spree in
Pennsylvania. The city of Newcastle Pennsylvania had a swamp nearby,
which had been used ever since the 1920s as a body dumping grounds during the
late 1930s, early 1940s, several headless victims were found at that location.
And people such as Marilou concluded that the so-called murder swamp killer and
the mad butcher of Kingsbury run one on the same.
This claim was investigated by the coroner's office and the police,
but it was never proven. As far as Elliot ness was concerned,
he became distressed and reckless due to mounting public pressure to stop the
killer on August the 18th, 1938,
just two days after the last victims were discovered,
the organized a massive raid on the shantytowns, the Kingsbury run.
He had all the vagrants rounded up and then he burns the police to the grounds
so they could not return.
It was the last act of a desperate man with no other cards to play.
NES was severely condemned in the newspapers for this extreme action.
But the thing is that the mad butcher never struck again.
We're not saying there is any direct correlation between the two.
We're just pointing it out.
The man bookshop.
I may have alluded capture,
but as far as Elliot nest and a few other detectives were concerned,
they identified the killer.
They were just not able to find evidence to take him to court.
One important talking point during the investigation was the extent of the
murderer's anatomical knowledge.
He always made precise cuts on the bodies of his victims,
knowing exactly where to slice.
So was he someone with medical experience or perhaps someone with more basic
training, like an actual butcher at one point, the coroner working the case,
Dr. Samuel Gerber expressed his belief that the killer was probably a doctor.
So the investigation began to focus on them.
Detectives started looking into medical professionals in Cleveland's with a
history, for any kind of licentious behaviors,
such as arrests for substance abuse. So soliciting prostitutes.
That is how they arrived at Dr. Francis Sweeney.
He was an alcoholic prone to violent outbursts. When he drank,
he grew up in Kingsbury,
rotten and had lost his marriage and his job due to his drinking problem.
Physically,
he fit the profile for the mad butcher because he was very tall and strong on
several occasions.
The killer had to carry the bodies of his victims up steep Hills.
So the police were convinced early on that he had to be a man of imposing
Snapchat. This all seemed promising,
but the investigators that two factors working against them,
one Francis Sweeney was the cousin of a Congressman Martin Sweeney.
The latter was the political opponents of mayor Burton and Elliot Nason
allegedly used his influence to impede the investigation of his cousin.
The second problem was that Sweeney often checked himself into a veteran's
hospital for his alcoholism,
and some of his stays coincided with the mad butchers notice.
This was enough to take focus off Sweeney for a while,
at least until one detective thought to look into the veterans hospital alibi
more closely. He discovered that because Sweeney was a doctor and his,
because he always admitted himself voluntarily.
It was pretty much free to come and go as he pleased.
And nobody kept close tabs on him because of this.
The investigation concentrated on him again,
but never yielded anything solid apart from a failed polygraph test and one
supposedly tense interrogation between ness and Sweeney,
where the former flat-out said that he believed Sweeney was the killer
prompting, the accused to grin from ear to ear,
standing up to show his massive frame, and then simply telling ness,
prove it for reasons. Still unknown today.
Francis weenie began checking into hospitals on a more permanent basis from
August, 1938 until his death.
He moved from hospital to hospital across the country. Then it's on occasion.
He sent rambling postcards study at NES. Again,
this happened shortly after the last of the mad butcher were found.
Although this was pure speculation,
some believed that his family forced him to do it, to stop the murders.
While at the same time avoiding the scandal of a trial.
There was one other note where the suspects a 52 year old brick lad named Frank
[inaudible], who was arrested in 1939 for the murder of Flo polo.
He gave a very strange confession,
which was part rambling part specific details,
which was later insinuated to have been coerced while [inaudible] was in the
custody of the County Sheriff's department. He was later found dead in his cell,
allegedly from hanging himself and as an autopsy revealed numerous bruises and
broken ribs.
Nobody's really sure why the Sheriff's department went so hard at dollars all
with almost no evidence,
some even floated the idea that they were under orders from someone higher up
the food chain who wanted another suspect other than the Francis Sweeney. Well,
if that's true, they didn't get it.
Nobody else seriously bought dollars all as a suspect for the mad butcher.
Even his so-called confession only admitted to killing Flo polo in self-defense.
When she attacked him with a knife,
the investigation lost steam pretty soon after the murders stopped Elliot ness
and many men on his team had no doubts that Sweeney was their killer.
So apart from keeping tabs on him, they moved on to new cases.
Others like Peter Marinello kept investigating the possibility that the killer
launched another murder spree in a different city as the years.
And then the decades pass the Cleveland torso murders became increasingly
forgotten. For some reason,
the mad butcher didn't enjoy the same everlasting infamy,
like other unidentified killers, such as Jack, the ripper or the Zodiac,
but he did end up local law. And as Cleveland's most new.
Korea's murderer.
Gonna ask whether you enjoy that video, but I do hope you found it interesting.
If you did, please do hit that thumbs up button below. Don't forget to.
Subscribe and thank you for watching.